live now to washington via uh munich
because uh president biden is
uh addressing the munich security
conference that's listening
to say hello to everyone and thanks you
uh the munich conference for hosting
this special session for decades as you
pointed out i participated in the munich
security conference
as a u.s senator joining my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle
to affirm the importance of the
trans-atlantic partnership
three times as the vice president united
states including delivering the first
international foreign policy address of
the obama biden administration
and the first months we were in office
and two years ago as
you pointed out when i last spoke in
munich i was a private citizen
i was a professor not an elected
official
but i said at that time we will be back
and i'm a man of my word america is back
i speak to you today as
president of the united states at the
very start of my administration
and i'm sending a clear message to the
world america
is back the transatlantic alliance is
back
and we are not looking backward we are
looking forward together
it comes down to this the transatlantic
alliance is a strong foundation
the strong foundation on which our
collective security
and our shared prosperity are built the
partnership
between europe and the united states in
my view is
and must remain the cornerstone of all
that we hope to accomplish
in the 21st century just as we did
in the 20th century the challenges you
face today are different
we're at an inflection point when i
spoke to you as a senator
and as even as vice president the global
dynamics have shifted
new crises demand our attention we
cannot focus only on the competition
among countries
that threaten to divide the world are
only on global challenges that threaten
to sync us
all together if we fail to cooperate we
must do
both working in lockstep with our allies
and partners
so let me uh erase any lingering doubt
the united states will work closely with
our european union partners
and the capitals across the continent
from rome to riga
to meet the range of shared challenges
we face
we continue to support the goal of
europe
whole and free and at peace
the united states is fully committed to
our nato alliance
and i welcome your europe's growing
investment in the military capabilities
that enable our shared defense
you know to me and to the united states
and
us we'll keep article we'll keep faith
with article 5.
it's a guarantee an attack on one
is an attack on all that is our
unshakable vow and the only time
article 5 has been invoked was after the
united states was attacked
on 9 11. you our allies joined us
to fight al-qaeda and the united states
committed to consulting closely
with our nato allies and partners on the
way forward in afghanistan
my administration strongly supports the
diplomatic proc
process that's underway and to bring an
end to this war
that is closing out 20 years
we remain committed to ensuring that
afghanistan never again provides the
base
for terrorist attacks against the united
states and our partners and our
interests
our european partners have also stood
with us to counter isis
just this week nato defense members
endorsed significant expanded
training and advisory mission in iraq
which will be vital to the ongoing fight
against isis
we cannot allow isis to reopen and
regroup and threaten people in the
middle east and europe and the united
states and elsewhere
and while the united states is
undergoing a thorough review of our own
force posture
around the world i've ordered the
halting of withdrawal of american troops
from germany
i'm also lifting a cap imposed by the
previous administration and the number
of u.s forces
able to be based in germany i know
i know the past few years have strained
and tested
our transatlantic relationship but the
united states is determined
determined to re-engage with europe to
consult with you
to earn back our position of trusted
leadership
earlier today as was referenced i
participated in the first meeting
of the g7 leaders where i spoke about
the dire need to coordinate
multilateral action to address covet 19
the global economic crisis and the
accelerating climate crisis
and so much else achieving these goals
is going to depend on a core strategic
proposition
and that is the united states must renew
america's enduring
advantages so that we can meet today's
challenges from a position
of strength that means building back
better our economic foundations
reclaiming our place in international
institutions
lifting up our values at home and
speaking out to defend them around the
world
modernizing our military capabilities
while leading with diplomacy
revitalizing america's network of
alliances and partnerships that have
made
the world safer for all people
you know i hope our fellow democracies
are going to join us in this vital work
our partnerships have endured and grown
through the years
because they are rooted in the richness
of our shared
democratic values they're not
transactional
they're not extractive they're built
on a vision of a future where every
voice matters
where the rights of all are protected
and the rule of law is upheld
none of this has fully succeeded in this
none of us has fully succeeding in this
division we continue to work toward it
and in so many places including in
europe and the united states
democratic progress is under assault
i've known for i know many of you for a
long long
time and you know that i speak my mind
so let me be very straightforward with
you all we are in the midst of a
fundamental debate
about the future and direction of our
world
we're at an inflection point between
those who argue
that given all the challenges we face
from the fourth industrial revolution
to a global pandemic that autocracy
is the best way forward they argue and
those who understand that democracy is
essential
essential to meeting these challenges
historians
are going to examine and write about
this moment
as an inflection point as i said and i
believe that
every ounce of my being that democracy
will and must prevail
we must demonstrate that democracy can
still deliver for our people
in this changed world that in my view is
our galvanizing mission
democracy doesn't happen by accident we
have to defend it
fight for it strengthen it renew it
we have to prove that our model isn't a
relic of history
it's the single best way to revitalize
the promise of our future
and if we work together with our
democratic partners
with strength and confidence i know
we'll meet every challenge and outpace
every challenger you know we must
prepare together
for long-term strategic competition with
china
how the united states europe and asia
work together to secure the peace
and defend our shared values and advance
our prosperity across the pacific
will be among the most consequential
efforts we undertake
competition with china is going to be
stiff
that's what i expect and that's what i
welcome
because i believe in the global system
europe and the united states together
with our allies in the indo-pacific
worked so
hard to build over the last 70 years
we can own the race for the future
but to do so we have to be clear-eyed
about the historic
investments and partnerships that this
will require
we have to protect we have to protect
for space
for innovation for intellectual property
and the creative
genius that thrives with the free
exchange of ideas in open democratic
societies
we have to ensure that the benefits of
growth are shared broadly and equitably
not just by a few we have to push back
against the chinese government's
economic abuses and coercion
that undercut the foundations of the
international economic system
everyone everyone must play by the same
rules
u.s and european companies are required
to publish this
publicly disclosed corporate governance
struck two corporate government
structures
and abide by rules to deter corruption
and monopolistic practices
chinese companies should be held to the
same standard we must shape the rules
that will govern
the advance of technology and the norms
of behavior in cyberspace
artificial intelligence biotechnology
so that they are used to lift people up
not used to pin them down
we must stand up for the democratic
values
and make it possible for us to
accomplish any of this
pushing back against those who would
monopolize and normalize
repression no this is also
this is also how we're going to be able
to meet a threat from russia
the kremlin attacks our democracies and
weaponizes corruption to try to
undermine
our system of governance russian leaders
want people to think that our system is
more corrupt or as corrupt as theirs
but the world knows that isn't true
including russians own russia's own
citizens
putin seeks to weaken european the
european project
and our nato alliance he wants to
undermine the transatlantic unity
and our resolve because it's so much
easier for the kremlin
to bully and threaten individual states
than it is to negotiate with a strong
closely united trans-atlantic community
that's why that's why standing up for
the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
remains a vital concern for europe and
the united states
that's why addressing recklessness
russian recklessness and hacking into
computer networks
in the united states and across europe
and the world has become
critical to protecting our collective
security
the challenges with russia may be
different than the ones with china
but they're just as real it is not about
pitting east against west
it's not about we want a conflict we
want a future where all nations are able
to freely determine their own path
without a threat of violence or coercion
we cannot and must not return to the
reflective opposition
and rigid blocks of the cold war
competition must not
lock out cooperation on issues that
affect us all
for example we must cooperate
if we're going to defeat covet 19
everywhere
my first presidential national security
memorandum focused on
surging health and humanitarian
responses to defeat cova 19
and to better prevent and prepare for
the next pandemic
today i'm announcing the united states
is making a 2 billion pledge to kovacs
with the promise of an additional 2
billion dollars
to urge others to step up as well yet
even as we fight to get out of the teeth
of this pandemic
the resurgence of ebola in africa is a
stark reminder
that we must simultaneously work to
finally
finance health security strengthen
global health systems
and create early warm warning systems
prevent
detect and respond to future biological
threats because they will
keep coming we have to work together
to strengthen and reform the world
health organization
we need a un system focused on
biological threats
that can move quickly to trigger action
similarly we can no longer delay
or do the bare minimum to address
climate change
this is a global existential crisis
and we'll all suffer we'll all suffer
the consequences if we fail
we have to rapidly accelerate our
commitments to aggressively curb our
emissions
and to hold one another accountable for
meeting our goals
and increasing our ambitions
that's why as president i immediately
rejoined the paris agreement
and as of today the united states is
officially once again a party
to the paris agreement which we helped
put together
on earth day i will host the leaders
summit
to help drive a more ambitious actions
among the top emitters including
domestic climate action here in the
united states
i am grateful i'm grateful for europe's
continued leadership on climate issues
over the last four years together
we need to invest in the technological
innovations that are going to power
our clean energy futures enable us to
build
clean energy solutions to global markets
the threat of nuclear proliferation also
continues to require
careful diplomacy and cooperation among
us
we need transparency and communication
to minimize the risk of strategic
misunderstanding or mistakes
that's why the united states and russia
notwithstanding another competition
extended the new start treaty for an
additional four years once i came
i was sworn in that's why we said we're
prepared to re-engage in negotiations
with the p5 plus one on iran's nuclear
program
we must also address iran's
destabilizing activities across the
middle east
and we're going to work in close
cooperation with our european and other
partners as we proceed
we'll also work together to lock down
fissile and radiological material to
prevent
terrorist groups from acquiring and
using them
look the range of challenges europe and
the united states must take on together
is broad and complex i'm either here i'm
eager to hear niggered here next
from my good friends and outstanding
leaders
senator merkel about her thoughts on the
way forward together
so let me conclude with this we cannot
allow self-doubt to hinder our ability
to engage each other
or the larger world the last
four years have been hard but europe and
the united states
have to lead with confidence once more
with faith in our capacities a
commitment to our own renewal
with trust in one another and the
ability of europe and the united states
to meet
any challenge to secure our futures
together
i know we can do this we've done it
before
just yesterday after a seven month
300 million mile journey
nasa successfully landed the
perseverance rover on mars
it's on a mission of exploration with
elements contributed by contributed by
our european partners
to seek evidence of the possibility of
life beyond our planet
and the mysteries of the universe over
the next few years
perseus has been called but perseverance
will range collect samples from the red
planet
and pile them up so another
mission and rover envisioned as a joint
effort between
nasa and the european states agencies
space agency
will retrieve this troll of scientific
wonders
and bring it home to all of us
that's what we can do together if our
unbound capacities to carry us to mars
and back
don't tell us anything else they tell us
we can meet
any challenge we can face on earth
we have everything we need i want you to
know the united states
will do we'll do our part we'll stand
with you
we'll fight for our shared values we'll
meet the challenges
of this new moment in history america is
back
so let's get together and demonstrate
to our great great grandchildren when
they read about us
that democracy democracy
democracy functions and works and
together
there's nothing we can't do so let's get
working
thank you all very much